Oh what's going on YouTube himself
recently I have been reading a lot of
comments and you guys have been saying
that you don't really get to know us
youtubers now I decided to go ahead and
think of a solution I decided to go
ahead and start a series called heart
heart with David so in this week's
episode we get up and close and personal
with the very famous ladies call Jas Lee
folly those who do not know who they are
you should probably go kill yourself
because the famous and the beautiful and
also my best friends did it go well you
asked take a look
hey hey look at me look at me
do not screw this up screw what up I'm
just a little excited
get a [ __ ] that's stupid perverted smile
on your face again there nice girl I'm
standing nice but look I'm not gonna do
anything stupid jackass does it fall in
love is that a crime David don't
hi it's nice to meet you yes mmm that's
the good stuff yeah get off then would
you stop hi how are you ladies doing
today really good thank you
well synchronizing everything huh that's
cute yeah so which one of yous engaged
that we mean really
how's that going I'm gonna call you Lily
it's really good good yes good not great
great great yeah great not excellent
excellent okay you guys you guys might
be getting divorces that detector heard
on Twitter feet it's that not true
love is not as hard to find sometimes
especially when you find in the weirdest
places such as in front of you right now
is this weird for you it's not can I
touch you for a second but okay oh you
little antsy there aren't you huh that's
cute
yeah um how did your boyfriend feel
about your success boyfriend are you
trying to figure out a friendly somebody
let's just say uh let me ask you
something
um do you want to go to kill it spills
me what's that mean boyfriend material
what Jesus is this stuff no it is now
hey you're engaged
I heard you ladies are quite the
Entertainer can you ladies tell us a
funny story how about that huh hmm yeah
Sarah whoo whoo yeah yeah yeah and went
to a bowling alley
that's great yes hey uh-huh and then
yeah oh that's hilarious
that's hilarious it said anything yet
anything funny so let's just go ahead
and continue this interview yeah sounds
good I'm just gonna do the rest
personally yeah oh this okay well now
that she's gone I sense a little animal
attraction No okay you said that a
little fast there want you go ahead and
think it over in your head a little bit
first did you just open your mouth
little bit I'm sorry I um I gotta go
hey just she wants me
what I mean ha ha not funny
my god it's a stupid my you comedian I
heard that uh Australia divorce Allah so
you should probably careful that oh
thanks honey Oh does he treat you right
I heard